on when I first fully got into porn I
was still I had moved here I had moved
back so I'm originally from LA but I
moved back to LA and that's when like
one of the First videos I did was one of
the biggest videos I did it was the
Bangbus video which gets oh everyone
knows what the big bus is that was my
first video I ever filmed so the first
day I went on he it was I was like very
new in the industry so I really didn't
think that people knew me so I told him
he told me that he like didn't watch
porn he wasn't in to any of it I told
him that I did only fans and then
literally in the middle I was like about
to hook up with this person and like he
opened his phone and his phone searched
history was looked up and it was just
Kiana kamani porn and there was like 10
search histories of my name